let's see if I remember to call it turn
left instead of left turn like I have in
other videos and just been chewed out by
the comments by everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
not that I'm bitter or anything hey
folks it is time for our overdue Doctor
Who review but before we get into it
allow me to remind you that this
particular episode of Council of geeks
is brought to you by the radio versus
the Martians podcast Mike Gillis and
Casey Doran host this wonderful show
with a rotating cast of guests as well
as any number of topics they might talk
about ghostbusters they'll talk about
comets they'll talk about Star Trek Star
Wars they'll talk about Arnold
Schwarzenegger movies oh boy will they
talk about Arnold Schwarzenegger movies
it's always fun it's often funny
sometimes it's even insightful radio
versus the Martians
it's the McLaughlin group for nerds is
that even still a current point of
reference is the McLaughlin group still
a thing I should look it up before I
keep repeating that in any case radio
versus the Martians calm or wherever you
get your podcasts so the penultimate
story since I consider two parters to be
the single story of series four turn
left
this was an interesting one for me to
revisit because I don't think as I don't
think of it as highly as a lot of other
people do which I think folks tend to
find odd given how much I love Donna
like Donna's my favorite companion
wouldn't I automatically love this well
there's a couple things about it
I do love Donna but I what makes Don
amazing is her chemistry with the doctor
and so when she's on her own she doesn't
suddenly become a bad character but it
is that dynamic that I love more than
anything else
so when you remove one half of that
equation that dynamic isn't in play
she's still a compelling character she's
still a good character she's still well
acted she still gets to act alongside
Wilf and a really nice you know guest
supporting cast in this but it's not
quite the same as her in the doctor so
that's the first thing that I think is
part of why I don't think is highly
about this as other ones and might be
the most substantive wasn't because the
other reasons are kinda nitpicks I
suppose a lot of it just has to do with
is one of those things where I've just
seen so many sci-fi shows or cartoons or
comics and this sort of what if one
thing was different story is a bit of a
staple and the thing is they nearly
always are super dark and depressing
that's like the whole point it's like
this one little thing is suddenly
everything is terrible
and then you go back to the way it was
that's you know I remember that with
with the season three Buffy episode the
wish or you know any number of it like
more that I can probably think of it's
kind of as soon as you are dealing with
an alternate timeline board work where
one tiny thing has changed I mean it's
the classic butterfly effect scenario
you know you're dealing with something
where everything's gonna go to hell
that's just the nature of it so just
having to sit there and watch it just
get worse
some more some more some worse Wow not
bad or unengaging it I know the tricks
that this thing has up his sleeve from a
very early point the story and I did the
first time I saw it and you know
watching it again I'm like I mean it's
good but I don't know I I don't want to
I don't want to accuse it of being
derivative because it's not like every
single thing doctor who has ever done is
like super unique but I don't know I
think maybe part of it is like I just
feel like he gets over praised I feel
like people latch on this and go it's so
original I'm like no lots of other stuff
have done that and that doesn't mean the
episode add it just makes me contrary to
the reaction maybe maybe I hold that
against this episode sometimes because I
know I've had that happen with other
things where it's not the thing I don't
like it's like the praise of it that
like sours me on it in a way and I
wonder if that's kind one of the things
that's kind of at play here but let like
I'm already getting into my complaints
alright what's good about this well
Catherine Tate is quite good and it is
interesting watching watch her and her
family who we've seen be so lively so
vibrant
vivacious just get hammered down by
thing after thing after thing going
wrong her mother especially is broken by
the end of this and Wilf when he's
seeing the I guess their Italian family
being loaded into the truck and noting
that labor camps that's what they called
them last time which i think is
something that felt slightly
manipulatives the wrong word but
something felt slightly like really did
you have to at the time a tear but I
mean I don't know rings it's me a little
harder now seeing that and
it's interesting how well thought out
this is that's something I will
absolutely give this credit for that
often times in these sort of butterfly
butterfly effect style stories in sci-fi
shows or fantasy shows or what have you
it's it's not always thoroughly thought
out like how much you would have to
cover and changing this is this is
pretty all-inclusive because Russell T
Davies had to figure out how to address
all the times that the doctor saved the
world but he's not alive to do it so how
do we deal with these things where it
doesn't result in the end of the earth
but it's still clear that this is worse
than when the doctor was here so you
have things like the hospital still goes
to the moon and comes back and almost
everyone there dies including Martha and
Sarah Jane who was there as well as the
the kids who are usually with her the
Atmos and the Sontarans do you get that
dealt with but that's the Torchwood team
gone and it's or the case of the Titanic
thing just crashes I know it might
technically be a minor pothole given
that it was supposed to actually land in
such a way that was going to destroy the
entire earth and just kind of radiates
the South of England but I mean you can
no prize that if you want to in some way
look at you know what well credited
Alonso will say Alonso managed to
contain it enough to keep it from
blowing up the entire planet along Z
Alonso but you know that just crashes
and kills so many people and it's a he
Russell T Davies really thought this out
the the full implications everything he
needed to cover and it's pretty
impressive Lee done Rose does good work
here as well she actually she has really
good chemistry
Donna also and she has a nice air of
mystery about her she has that air of
you can tell she's excited at the
possibility of seeing the doctor again
but she also sees all the damage going
on around her and she is not immune to
that she's well aware of it and that
that goes over really well too and oh
the just the looks between the two of
them when Donna says that you know I'll
go back and I'll change his thing and
then I won't die and just the look from
Rose and saying I'm sorry because she
knows the Donna at least this version of
Donna is going to die is going to have
to die it's it is a very
well-put-together thing for what it is
it's just for whatever reason what it is
just doesn't really strike a chord with
me on a more nitpicky note I've
complained about this before I don't
like the design of the time bug or
whatever the heck it's official name is
I I just like it because I find it lazy
given that so much of the premise of the
thing is you can't get a proper look at
in people will kinda like think they see
it but then when they look at it
properly they don't see it at all it
annoys me that it's just a bug this is a
really big bug which is you know kind of
achy a little bit but like I really wish
that they had taken advantage of the
idea that you can't quite see it
properly - first of all not ever show it
properly but to hint at something way
more monstrous I wish they had gone you
know Cthulhu asked on this and I don't
mean like literally designing something
that looks like Cthulhu I mean taking
that note of you know if you've ever
read Lovecraft the way that things get
described is often in these vagaries
that you can't quite wrap your head
around because it's describing something
that we're not meant to see I kind of
wish that we had just gotten tiny
glimpses of something that doesn't quite
make
cents and how do you do that I don't
know like there's gotta be a weird
comparison but I remember when I saw
Cloverfield in the theater and what I
really liked about it up until the very
end where we finally got a good look at
the monster one of the things I really
liked about is the way that it was
designed with how spindly its limbs were
and the angles at which it bent and how
it moved it meant that when you had the
ground level view with the thing and you
just saw pieces of it like passing
between buildings for brief glimpses
what you saw didn't make sense or you
see one bit of it like how does that you
couldn't like gel that with the bit
you'd seen before like you couldn't
these tiny snippet in you couldn't get a
complete picture of this thing in your
mind like no this doesn't make sense
and I wish that the thing on her back
was like that where we get these tiny
glimpses of it like things that are
incongruous and like wait a minute how
can that be the same thing what like it
would have been hard I'm not saying it
wouldn't have this wouldn't have been
easy but like it was such an opportunity
to do something unique in like really
unsettling and it's just a big bug and
that annoys me I do like that gets marks
at the trick part of the tricksters
brigade because the trickster if you've
never seen Sarah Jane Adventures it was
kind of the big recurring villain of the
Sarah Jane Adventures so that was kind
of cool to get a to get a firmer link
between the things that Sarah Jane has
to deal with and that the doctor deals
with so I've seen some people say they
want the trickster to be pulled over
into Doctor Who I'm not sure I agree
with that because I mean he's he works
very well as a Sarah Jane but he's he's
a little cheesy but I mean Sarah Jane
Adventures was very much for younger
kids so he worked there but I don't know
about that one
but I thought the link was cool and
there's something it's a nice build to
just have bad wolf
suddenly it's everywhere you like Oh oh
crap and it lays out so much of the
stuff that's about to pay off the next
story between the stars going out the
bees disappearing gets another mention
rose bad wolf like all this stuff and
it's all gonna come to a head in the
next story so this one this one does a
lot it has to tell a self-contained
story a self-contained sort of what-if
depressing story and at the same time as
setup so much stuff that it needs to be
in place for the next one
and Oh Donna because this this has to
set up and this really hammers that fact
that she does not she honestly does not
believe she's important like down to her
soul she doesn't believe that like when
the ideas suggested her that she is
important just the how dismissive she
had like she's insulted by the idea that
someone would even suggest she's
important she plays that really well and
so like ultimately this is good this is
a good episode but it's just what it's
doing this isn't quite my bag it's not
bad it does it well but aside from a
couple of knit picks that again are
pretty specific to me I just think this
just isn't my kind of story butterfly
effect style stories rarely do much for
me so I guess I kind of just chalk it up
to that and and call it a day
it's still good stuff though turn left
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it whole
bunch of stuff to do down there cuz you
know there's buttons and links there's
like button that's a big help people
been hitting it lately and I appreciate
it
there's also the patreon I'd appreciate
that as well subscribe if you have and
check out my socials my book links are
all down there but you also don't have
to click on them I'd appreciate it but
you know what at the end of the day I'm
not gonna tell you what to do because
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]